هذا المكان الذي ضرب من المفترض انه التي
انطلقت منه صواريخ قبل قليل
والطائرات الاسرائيليه تقصف في مكان اطلاق
الصواريخ كان في محيط كان في هدف في محيط
منطقه سفينه للمره الثالثه وهدف اخر
بمنطقه البيدر بغرب غزه وهدف في جنوب غزه
وفقا لما افادت به وسائل الاعلام
الفلسطينيه لم ترد بعد لدينا تقارير واضحه
عن سقوط قتل او جرحى جراء هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه على القطاع ولكن اسرائيل تقول
انها تاثير ردا على اطلاق صواريخ من
القطاع صوب جنوب اسرائيل كان الجيش اعلن
فعلا عن شنغارات جويه على مواقع في
القطاع وان الفصائل الفلسطينيه في قطاع
غزه اطلقت رشقات صاروخيه باتجاه مستوطنات
غلاف القطاع دون ذكر المزيد من التفاصيل
طبعا هذه التطورات تاتي بعد
الاخبار التي يعني اتت منذ هذا اليوم عن
وفاه الاسير الفلسطيني خبر عدنان وهو الذي
ادى الى موقف فلسطيني
متفاعل مع هذا الخبر ومن ثم الى اطلاق
الصواريخ قبل اعلان
اسرائيل اذا عن شنها ضربات جويه على مواقع
في قطاع غزه هذه اخر المعلومات والصور
التي تردنا من القطاع وسيكون لنا وقفه مع
مراسلينا بعد قليل لكي نتعرف اكثر على
حقيقه الوضع هناك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والو
ثائق ناتنه على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات